hey wisecrack Jared here today we have a
special episode on an artist who forces
us to think about our own mortality
among other things what's the point of
thinking Kanye West's
following Kanye gives you the feeling of
watching a train filled with $300
sneakers crash into a guy dressed as
Jesus but at the same time he projects a
certain sincerity that seems to
contradict his otherwise impulsive image
I'm really happy for you I'm let you
finish there's no doubt that Kanye
thinks Kanye is a philosopher I don't
think we should go quite that far but
Kanye does share at least one concern
with 19th century Danish philosopher
søren kierkegaard death like a lot of
feelings about death welcome to this
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
Kanye West and death part 1 death
anxiety Kanye has never been shy about
mentioning death we're all gonna die one
day in his 2005 Grammy Award speech he
spoke about his experience with a car
accident and his discovery that nothing
in life is promises septet Kanye has
repeated similar sentiments throughout
his career only luxury is time only
thing promised is that you gonna die one
day so we just we don't let us to the to
the maximum through the wire recorded
when yays jaw was still wired shut from
his 2002 car accident describes his
narrow miss with death and his triumphal
for the situation at the hands of a
guardian angel frankly I'm surprised to
give the angel any credit at all this
interest in death is pretty explicit
starting from his first album the
college dropout where we hear
[Music]
on one of his most recent tracks waves
he keeps it short and simple waves don't
die empower Kanye fantasizes about a
beautiful day
and his 30-minute art film run away
opens with an excerpt from Mozart's
Requiem which is of course a mass for
the dead
okay so Kanye has some strong feelings
about death so what Kierkegaard's
philosophy tells us that despair over
our mortality is pretty inevitable
unless we embrace our relationship with
the big guy upstairs
the notorious g.od Jesus is pretty key
to coping with our worries about death
because having faith in him means that
death isn't actually the end for you for
Kanye this despair is revealed in his
fixation on mortality his desire to live
in the moment and perhaps his desire to
evade death altogether you know the
saying that a man may die but an idea
will live forever Kanye has bought into
that big-time accept the idea that will
preserve Kanye is Kanye you don't think
I would be one of the characters of
today's modern Bible by positioning
himself as a musician producer fashion
designer reality star and frequent
commentator on everything and whatever
he next pursues I have decided in 2020
to run for president Kanye is doing more
than expressing himself
maybe he's cultivating a kind of
celebrity that is so ubiquitous he
achieves some kind of immortality like
Kierkegaard's works kanye deals with
mortality in three ways distracting
himself with cool [ __ ] trying to be a
good person and striving to somehow make
himself eternal so he doesn't have to
worry about all that [ __ ] anyway or in
the words of Kierkegaard the aesthetic
the ethical and the religious Kanye is a
walking contradiction private and
radically public meticulous and
spontaneous Beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time so why can't he live
the contradiction of embracing his
inevitable death and also trying to live
forever bear with me for a second
Kierkegaard tells us that in order to be
cured of the despair that arises from
this contradiction one must understand
his/her own self and the nature of that
self and to get there they can progress
through three consecutive states of
existence
Kanye does all three is the similarity
to Kierkegaard a total accident
born of too much cocaine and a god
complex bigger than Kim Kardashian's
personality possibly but we're here to
figure it out anyway so let's get to it
stage one less dying more pardons the
hedonistic spectacle of Kanye is pretty
much exactly what Kierkegaard would
define as the aesthetic we can see this
in Kierkegaard's 1843 philosophy texts
either
or grab a drink grab a glass after that
I grab you ass kidding that's definitely
Kanye but Kierkegaard does tell us that
the aesthetic man lives his life in
pursuit of desire and pleasure often
interpreting himself as if you were
always on a stage sound familiar to get
a better grasp of Kierkegaard stages
think about a corn dog when you're young
corn dogs are really delicious and
that's pretty much all that matters you
don't think about the stomachache you'll
have in the morning or your future bowel
movement or dog equals yummy that's all
that matters and that's the aesthetic
stage it's easy to find examples of
aesthetic debauchery and Kanye's work
although that's not exactly unique among
rappers what's more interesting is the
way in which Kanye's aesthetic
embodiment is so over-the-top and
enduring as seen most vividly in his
music videos Kanye takes the typical sex
and drugs imagery of a hip-hop video and
draws out the obscenity makes it
self-aware and really crafts it into a
kind of art this is the video for famous
off his most recent album and while it
certainly doesn't shy away from
controversy it's also a pretty
interesting social and political
statement I'm about the [ __ ] Kanye
West for someone who lives on a stage
both metaphorically and also kind of
literally Kanye has a lot to say about
his privacy
Kanye has said that one of his biggest
concerns with paparazzi is the fact they
have on his family especially his
daughter this is a different side of
Kanye than the one we see yelling about
being Shakespeare
I am Shakespeare in the flesh but it's
certainly not an altogether different
character far from it Kanye's sometimes
outlandish aesthetic serves as a kind of
frame to his familial and ethical
considerations and we know Kanye loves
frames staged to family ethics and
politics
Kanye's relationship with his wife and
children is one of his most clearly
humanizing characteristics family time
yeah it's what it's what Kim gave me she
gave me everything using one of his many
pseudonymous characters Kierkegaard
argues that the transition from the
aesthetic stage of self-discovery to the
ethical stage is exemplified in marriage
a person in the aesthetic stage is
focused only on the momentary pleasures
of the erotic and marriage forces them
to commit to something long-term which
changes their priorities we see evidence
of this in Kanye's most recent album the
life of Pablo the first years released
since marrying
him pitchfork describes this album as
the moments that the artist finally
settles down after years of turbulent
affairs and probably one too many
pregnancy scares let's go back to our
corn dog example at some point you might
discover that corn production requires a
tremendous amount of water and has a lot
of potential to do economic and
environmental damage then even your own
personal health concerns might take a
backseat to your commitment to something
higher than yourself the welfare of the
planet that's Kierkegaard's ethical
stage besides his relationship with his
family we see Kanye most actively
engaged in the ethical spear in his
advocacy for racial and class justice I
care about people Kanye has been vocal
in addressing inequalities since the
very beginning of his career everybody a
hip-hop discriminates against gay people
and this hasn't changed as he's gathered
more Fame in different projects George
Bush doesn't care about black people and
he draws much of his musical influences
from the soul music of the civil rights
era we also see consistent mentions of
racial and class justice in his own
lyrics
the message that we hear on track music
from 2005 is a similar one to the
message in murder to excellence in 2011
and new slaves in 2013 Kanye's work
often speaks to the ways in which deeply
entrenched power dynamics within our
society can perpetuate the oppression of
people of color and those from the
working class his commitment to certain
moral ideas about justice outside of
what just benefits him or his family is
the mark of someone operating in the
ethical stage of self-discovery or just
you know common human decency half the
time 67 percent on that say in popular
opinion I'm saying stuff that I believe
stage 3 praise Jesus
remember that Kierkegaard says the whole
reason to even talk about these stages
is because they help you to escape
despair to escape despair you must
accept your true nature which means
realizing that you are bound to Christ
and then you can basically just kill the
[ __ ] up Kierkegaard is 100% onboard the
Jesus boat so he's not actually worried
about his own death but he knows you
probably are and he just wants to throw
you a big old Christian lifesaver
Kanye has one leg in the Jesus boat and
one leg in his own boat on the one hand
he's been consistently vocal about his
relationship to the big JC remember that
one of his first big hits was Jesus
and that theme of religious devotion has
stayed in his music even up through his
latest album which samples gospel tracks
and opens with the lyrics this is a God
dream but on the other hand Kanye is
pretty insistent that he is God and God
and he doesn't seem to be too concerned
about blasphemy we could really spend an
entire day dissecting just this one song
he calls himself a God he acknowledges
his connection to another God and he is
extremely insistent on the timely
delivery of his baked goods hurry up
with my damn croissants that's not the
only time Kanye has referred to himself
as a God I mean the guy named himself
yeezus in simi now a bonus track off my
Beautiful Dark Twisted Fantasy he says
he is Lord and refers to his G DS which
rap genius told me means Gangster
Disciples
he's also spoken about his apparent
divinity on stage and in interviews
where he gives a somewhat more nuanced
approach I just told you who I thought I
was Oh God
wow I really can't argue with that
alright Kanye you win you're a god Jesus
when angelic language and imagery appear
all over his work the presence of angels
is especially strong in his music videos
no church in the wild power and the 30
minute film run away all feature winged
women he also just released a trailer
for a video game which focuses on his
dead mother's ascension to heaven no
really that's the thing the game itself
hasn't been released yet but we're
guessing that the player gets to guide
mama west up to the pearly gates which
is basically leaving the fate of his
mother's eternal salvation in the hands
of gamers not sure Kanye thought that
one through
Kanye's tense relationship between
himself as God and the Christian God
might be representative of the despair
that he's trying to evade as previously
mentioned despair is characterized by a
tension between a desire for the
temporal the right here on earth and the
eternal as a god Kanye hopes to achieve
earthly immortality through the legacy
of his work while as a believer in
another God Kanye gives his life over to
someone else for Kierkegaard religion is
the highest stage of existence and
self-discovery it's where you realize
that the corndog actually belongs to
someone else and oh damn where did this
corndog come from how did it even end up
in my hand where am I who are you what
are you doing with all these corn dogs
yeah now
you're the corn dog and you belong to
Jesus in the religious stage you
recognize that reason and belief can
only get you so far
rather than belief which can be grounded
improve or in reason you need faith
which is totally beyond the bounds of
logic here card describes faith as
passionate inwardness which is also
probably a pretty good description for
Kanye that beyond logic part is
important since coming up with rational
arguments about death has never made
anyone feel more ok about death when you
look at it scientifically rotting in a
hole isn't all that great
I suppose one way to no longer care
about death is to believe in your own
godliness the immortality of his work
isn't important unless he knows it so
the performance art trainwreck that is
Kanye West's public persona really just
exists as a conversation with himself
but does that surprise you
for the art but what I believe in final
thoughts so Kanye is trying to turn
himself into a God at the same time that
he believes in the god of Christianity
and he's doing this because he's really
confused about death but how much of his
aesthetic ethical and religious action
is just a matter of him saying whatever
pops into his head and how much of it is
intentional it's impossible to say for
sure but maybe it's worth some thought
he's a lot smarter than people sometimes
are willing to give him credit for hey
Kanye really escaped his anxieties about
death by creating an artistic legacy to
leave behind
forget the sick beats or the VMA antics
maybe the real reason Kanye has such a
massive following is that he gives voice
to a certain dread that we all have in
common or maybe he's just really good at
Twitter hey everyone thanks for watching
if you'd like to hear more Kanye we've
got a bunch of ideas for other episodes
so definitely let us know in the
comments a great way to support the show
is by supporting our sponsors this
episode is sponsored by audible
honorable has an unmatched selection of
audio books original audio shows comedy
news and much more go to audible.com
slash wisecrack to start a free 30-day
trial and when you sign up you can pick
any book you want download it for free
and it's yours to keep forever if you're
looking for a recommendation we really
enjoyed moonwalking with Einstein by
Joshua Foer it's a book that follows one
man's journey from an everyday forgetful
guy into a competitive memory champion
and it teaches you the art and science
of remembering everything for more
audible and to start your 30-day free
trial with a free audiobook go to
audible.com slash wisecrack to sign up
hey guys thanks for watching and thanks
for all the support be sure you
subscribe and I'll see you next week
peace
[Music]